[Music]
dr. Weaver received his doctorate in
electrical engineering from the
University of Michigan
it was Archibald MacLeish then head of
the Library of Congress who invited him
to establish and operate a recording and
acoustics laboratory within the library
and now 30 years later
what would Archibald MacLeish say of
Jerome Wiesner ladies and gentlemen I
ask mr. McLeish to step to the lectern
I have called these lines speech for an
occasion the occasion obviously is this
one and I have dedicated them to the
occasion of the occasion Jerry Wiesner
rinsing our mouths with praise tin cup
but the limestone spring in the cool of
the mint bed earlier generations knew
this place made their way here thronging
we have forgotten it we have kept to the
streets to long tongues stale hearts
thirsty o to praise God's will in the
world if we could learn it test it on
our lips would taste of praise why else
should the world be beautiful why should
the leaves look as they do the light in
the water rinsing our mouths with praise
of a good man I say what I mean I do not
say a good man in a bad time old times
are bad when the man fails them I say a
good man at a time when men are scarce
when the intelligent for gather follow
each other around in the fog like sheep
bleat in the rain complain because
godo never comes because all life is a
tragic absurdity Sisyphus sweating away
at his stone and this rock won't because
freedom and dignity Oh weep they say for
freedom and dignity you're not free it's
your grandfather's it's your scratching
you have no dignity you're not a man
you're are wrapped in a vat of rewards
and punishments you think you've chosen
the rewards you haven't the rewards have
chosen you I weep rinsing our mouths
with praise of a good man in a time when
men are scarce when the word chirps like
a cricket on the cellar floor on the
damp stone and the mind wanders a good
man looked him there in the fog look he
saunters along to his place in the
world's weather lights his pipe hitches
his pants talks back to accepted
opinions congressional committees hear
him say and not what you think what you
haven't thought of he addresses presence
he says governments even now still have
to govern no one is going to invent a
self-governing Holocaust the Pentagon
receives his views science he says is no
substitute for thought miracle drugs
perhaps not miracle wars advisor the
president's the papers call him advisor
I say to the young it's the young who
need competent friends bold companions
honest men who won't run out won't write
off mankind sell up the country quit the
venture jive the ship
people in Cambridge off of that drive
bit it's still under payments just help
each other rating says the professor
from Berkeley from the USFL where is
worth then families up at the island one
in a car yeah and he will come and say
what the rights are tell them all of
this one car one car and that will be
sometime within the next five to ten
minutes the out of the way because
people are going to come in that way
okay
[Applause]
you don't have to actually go out and
ask every student what's your opinion on
this issue why don't my gonna have
opinions on any random issue that you
pick but you've got to at least say we
are about to make a decision on this
kind of thing anybody who's interested
you know please submit comments now
three years ago this institute went to a
big decision of shouldn't we have a
medical school I didn't know about it
I've been here five years and all the
time I was here nobody even suggested
that we were going through that kind of
a discussion why not why is that we
couldn't afford to have a big exercise
in frustration I should we shouldn't we
have a million school that we didn't
have a hundred million dollars that
we're going to take the bill the only
way we could say yes is if we could find
somebody who would match the government
money with fifty the promise of fifty
million dollars cash and dr. Killian and
I said let's try and then we can and we
hit five people that we knew doors X
people and then we finally talked to
this someone we couldn't even reach who
we thought were interested enough in
medical schools MIT a hole or nothing to
see whether anyone was willing you know
to say sure the six months before we had
been totaling up the bill on what we
thought it was going where we were gonna
have to raise to do the things we
thought already had to be done to keep
the promises that had been made like
dormitories and new buildings as harm
and that came to two hundred million
dollars that we didn't have you know and
I don't see why that kind of a decision
has to be put to a popular referendum in
a referendum I think they just have to
say that you're making it
one of the students might have known
somebody with fifty million dollars in
the pocket we're faced with a question
whether the decisions about today makes
sense for this kind of group I think
it's fine to go into the other things
but I think we also ought have come to
some understanding as to whether or not
we're involved in a decision-making
process that makes sense or is this
another Medical School deal I love this
man I rinse my mouth with his praise and
a frightened time the taste in the cup
is of mint of spring water
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much mr. McLeish and now
as chairman of the corporation of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and on behalf of that body I shall
proceed to induct into office our 13th
president dr. Killian and dr. Scott
please bring it forward
by the authority of the corporation and
with the enthusiastic approval of the
faculty alumni and the student body and
of this distinguished assembly I present
into your keeping this charter of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and invest you with all of the authority
privileges and responsibilities of the
office of President may you Jerry serve
the Institute and dignify its office of
president with all of the skill wisdom
and dedication which our confidence
Accords to you and may your
administration be memorable
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You mi t--'s pride of presidents
no friend Archibald MacLeish for this
honor of its own a new Paul Gray that
you become a legal chancellor for being
willing to share the burden of joys of
leading this great institution and a
special thanks to Priscilla gray and in
my wife Leila
first a willingly taking the pungent
with us into the unknown exciting but
obviously demanding future dear friends
thank you all for this occasion I might
just say in passing dr. Killian has made
me realize that I had something to look
forward to
[Music]
you